that's gum right hi and welcome to
problem they are Cherie fun fact if you
switch the letters around it becomes pro
baby oh yeah as I guess we started with
the target practice so I have the
ability to jerk my hand also I can do
that in the game I'm so sorry
oh okay I can do this too which is great
for slapping strippers and buds which is
also something you can do in the game oh
okay cool
this is not correct man how is this not
good enough then Guardian Leviosa oh god
that's disgusting
it's this not how you Archer and now we
move the left arm oh my god I'm a genius
oh [ __ ] I can do all cat what is
happening here what is this
you know what it's perfect it's perfect
that's what it [ __ ] it that's the
best arrow I've seen in my entire life
that's even better
why stop stop oh [ __ ] here we go oh my
god the only thing like 30 minutes all
right let's get all of them it's okay
it's okay
wael I'll watch him together how did
this guy even get anywhere in life
guess the words coordinating skills I
ever seen oh breakdown do the Gangnam
style no no I bad you don't want I'm not
sure you want to do that Bob your mom is
over there okay let's do it
traditionally really you can do like
this
that's dumb man that actually makes
sense I don't like that all right
got my mind on my target got my target
on my mind baby well I hate the rope I
hit the [ __ ] rope like archery
archery is for like cool people and [ __ ]
sorry I
yes BAM Bobby Bo Bobby Bo I will buy
your new shoes
- how about that sure thing yeah well I
guess I'll get on that okay now that we
have some practice we can do what the
egg step okay we're doing the
exterminator the more you break and the
longer you take the less you'll watch
god I hate eggs we got this price okay
just just just [ __ ] get it and please
please for the love of God just put it
in I can't wait any longer
I want it I want to [ __ ] the egg it's
like it's your first time doing this I
swear to God okay now let go of my ass
no not that ass come on
what from the head how are you even
there we go holy [ __ ]
you hit my ass that felt really good
just breathe just breathe breathing I
didn't want to run up to that little
[ __ ] and stab him in the ass oh okay
here we go oh I swear to God if you let
go one more [ __ ] time I'm not gonna
hit ten eggs you [ __ ] high okay I got
I got you Dean
ah - okay I'm gonna [ __ ] get that egg
I'm shooting from my den at all it makes
me feel a little better about the
situation where is it just got slapped
in the face there's another one of
course how in the hell oh come one come
on man
comma one come on came in ah ah egg it's
like the new [ __ ] flappy bird I swear
to God
oh [ __ ] this [ __ ] this [ __ ] this
I got thank that's all we got war ban
that sounds oh god what some kinky
Japanese [ __ ] I've seen enough hentai to
know whether this is going
actually I don't I don't watch hentai
hey I promise mom mom mom wait non-stop
how do you even know what that is mom
that kind of freaks me out actually holy
[ __ ] why don't I just run for it why not
no I must stand and fight with my
amazing war skills there's nothing we
can't accomplish now if only I could
figure out how to move these arms yeah
we're [ __ ]
it's not fair they have swords man and
they're naked it's destroyed
no it's night mom I always hate you what
what what what
the gods are on our side oh my [ __ ]
god this is awesome oh god oh god
sexy men is coming why Gaga why I said
baraka burns dang you might be thinking
what about your nonsense if you look up
Baraka in a Nixon era it says stick with
something sharp
and there you go romance Bravo
okay what else do we got Berserker oh
okay I can't shut up this is really
annoying okay you're actually stressing
me I don't like when I get okay I'm
gonna wait for it okay here's a tiny
little fetus head that's awesome ah hey
apple pie for dinner baby
oh yes shield Oh God hey oh god he's
bald oh god he's bald
oh god oh scared me people oh oh my god
this is stressing me so much no I got a
guy they're so sexy look at them little
feet his heads in shame
Oh what are they doing guys stop stop my
video is gonna get censored oh god oh
god oh my god not again
oh god oh god oh god I got [ __ ] [ __ ]
you [ __ ] you so [ __ ] much [ __ ] no no
no no goddamn the show of
before that's some real [ __ ]
inception [ __ ] man
and I'm gonna explain to me why I'm a
balloon what's her name Adam uh okay
clever I get it I know it's you who's
drunk Adam but to be honest I had a
couple of drinks too and I don't know
how to say this in a nice way but you're
a [ __ ] Apple I mean you're gonna die
I mean that's not better either I seem
to have some coordinate coordination
prop Derek not a thing ignore what I
just said because you don't know me and
that's rude
I'm quite frankly a little bit of yeah
okay
just gonna try and figure this out yeah
that's that's working that's good that's
good
that's not really what I want oh oh oh
God how the [ __ ] am I gonna hit that
don't worry that was just uh to see if
you were ready
God Evan what I have to be so fabulous
that's like the problem in this game I'm
a [ __ ] professional okay dare you
question my integrity
okay the same for his balls okay I'll
get your yellow punk ass [ __ ] yeah
that's right
I want your naked butt no I don't I
don't want I don't mom mom I'm not gay
mom I have a girlfriend we've been up
you're embarrassing me yeah that'll do
it oh my let's press yes this has been
probably entry it was a lot of fun hope
you had fun watching they were like if
you did and I hope you have a great one
drive safe you know try it okay
you
buttercup